welcome everyone my name is Talia cantes
and today we're going to be talking
about Magnus Carlson at the Tata steel
Chess Championship going on in wanser
his losses but most importantly his wins
let's get right into it so the wona is
actually one of the strongest uh chess
tournaments going on in the world and as
well as one of the longest running and
this particular Edition is very
interesting because you have a bunch of
established Elite chess players and at
the same time a bunch of newcomers into
the elite chess scene uh in up until
round three Magnus Carlson was one of
the top uh players leading the event
however in round four he has he had a
very interesting game against Anish giri
uh where Anish actually played a really
beautiful game uh let into an endg game
with a Pawn on the seventh rank pair of
Bishops and after a really beautiful B4
move he managed to open up some files
for the rook and the position just kept
on becoming more and more unbearable for
Magnus uh this was a very special win
for Anish giri as he mentioned in his
interview and he was very glad to
finally win a game against Magnus after
12 years of fighting and struggling he
did accredit the fact that uh Magnus had
been taking more and more risks against
him in the last couple of games that
they have played therefore giri had some
chances to get wild positions against
Magnus and have some chances of a
decisive
game following that Magnus Carlson
played Norbeck Abdus satov who's one of
the rising uh junior players in the
world right now second place at the
Olympiad in
2022 as well as being board one for the
gold winning team uh in this game Magnus
Carlson with the white pieces decided to
take some more risks and he gave up an
exchange uh in the middle game to try
and get back back some initiative
against the black king and some open
files to create counterplay however all
of the material became uh a really
strong pressure point for Magnus and he
ended up uh letting his counterplay slip
and the position led to a very nice very
instructive Queen end game which I
highly recommend if any of you want to
study Queen end games more and the
theory of them uh mother back had the
upper hand in the game from the from the
middle game and he let it all the way
into the end game not giving Magnus a
chance to even make a draw and this was
the second consecutive loss for Magnus
which marked a really huge uh point
because he has not lost two games in a
row since
2015 so what happens now after two very
devastating losses in a tournament where
Magnus uh had been asked previously
about his aims to reach 2900 it must be
extremely disappointing um especially at
the top levels you often don't see
players losing games so frequently uh
they tend to be very solid very concise
very uh cold- headed at times
and uh this is just a rare occurrence
it's very fun to watch as a as a chess
fan but for the players it can be hard
breaking at times however uh one very
interesting point is the way that Magnus
completely came back after those uh two
losses and he managed to win three games
in a row against Risha raport Fabiano
Carana and uh Paran
maxu let's get into round seven of the
tournament Magnus Carlson with the white
pieces against streer report it was a
very interesting game started off as a
pet and soon enough it got into very
interesting territory with night KN to
D3 usually players would do Knight to F3
and this would lead to Mainline Theory
however uh recently Knight to D3 has
become a very popular approach because
after Knight takes E4 Queen to E2 Queen
to E7 Knight to F4 and the idea now is
to go Knight to D5 and put some pressure
on the queen uh of course black pie is
not is not going to allow that
especially uh someone on strongest
report Pawn to C6 was played F3 Knight
to F6 Pawn to D4 and you might be
thinking okay there is no reason why to
go for this line there is a queen trade
so suddenly and it's going to be very
difficult to find any advantage this
just going to be an end game but uh as
you can see raport decided to play with
Bishop to F5 and the idea is that the
queen trade sure is an end game but at
the same time white has a very
comfortable position the king's going to
go to F2 and soon enough there will be
be gaining space on the king side with
G4 and
H4 in the game Bishop to F5 was played
Pawn to C4 H5 Knight to C3 Knight A6
with a very clear idea of bringing the
Knight to B4 and potentially
C2 King to F2 was
played Knight to B4 Queen to
D1 and right now you can see that okay
both sides are in the process of
developing and getting their pieces out
of the way but it just seems so much
more natural for black than it is for
white the king going to F2 the queen
going back to D1 it's not so clear how
Magnus is going to uh finish off his
development however after Castle Knight
to D3 Pawn to D5 was played by by raport
and the player with the white pieces has
to be extremely careful because the dile
is about to be open up the pawn on D4 is
going to become completely isolated and
as we know if the king is still in the
center or it has a very unclear
situation it is good to open up the the
position and that is what black is
aiming
towards so the only move here that does
not give advantage to Black is the one
that was played Pawn to C5 and after
Knight takes D3 Bishop takes C3 Knight 2
E4 was played and to surprise of no one
uh this was a very um creative
combination by raport who uh loves this
type of play uh the issue is that after
Pawn takes Pawn takes Bishop to E2 the
question is how to continue right
and the compensation for black is going
to be mainly this defile the possibility
of the queen jumping out and the king
the white king just being so
exposed Queen to F6 was played Bishop to
E3
the only problem is that this bishop on
F5 does not actually have any great
discovery for example if this bishop was
not on E2 uh black could play Bishop to
G4 and get the queen but the bishop is
on way and it means that this bishop on
F5 sure can move out of the way and give
a check but it doesn't create any extra
threat beyond
that Bishop to C5 was played playing
with the fact that there is a pin on the
queen here on
D1 but Carlson says okay you go take my
Pawn I play Rook to F1 I'm going to
bring my king to G1 and all of a sudden
I'm going to be fine it's going to be
like nothing happened uh like I castled
the normal way right uh Queen to H4 King
to G1 and all of a sudden it's not so
clear how black is going to continue it
feels like the best that could have
happened for them already already went
away and now it's more about creating
some sort of um Checkmate that either
completely works or doesn't work but the
great thing about the top players in the
world is that they just have impeccable
defensive skills so Bishop to D6 clearly
going after H2 and Magnus says okay you
can take my Pawn Rook takes F5 Queen
takes H2 King to F1 and it's not clear
at all how uh black is going to get
material back for this queen to H1
Bishop to G1 Pawn to G6 asking The Rook
where it's going and Magnus just keeps
on taking material Rook takes F7 there
is no fear of opening up the f file
Bishop to C4 protecting the bishop uh
Bishop to H2 was played going after G1
but just for example if Rook takes F7
Bishop takes F7 uh Rook f8 there's Queen
B3 and all of a sudden it's not so clear
who is going to who is going to be under
attack right because after Bishop to H2
there is some Queen E6 and it looks like
the black king is also in a lot of
trouble soon enough King to F2 can be
played and white can get um away with
taking all the pieces and running
away so Bishop to H2 was playing in the
game King to F2 Rook takes F7 Bishop
takes F7 Rook to f8 Queen B3 there the
almost the same line Bishop takes G1
Rook takes G1 Queen to H4 King E2 and
after a couple of moves uh it was very
obvious that black didn't have enough
even after taking the bishop on F7 the
Knight comes back to E2 uh White is a
piece up and the black pawns will never
be enough Queen to H3 take six Rook F3
Rook to G3 and here uh Richard rort
resign with the black pieces uh in his
interview Magnus Carlson said that he
was looking forward to this game as a
way to come back into the tournament and
that he was really glad that Richard
Rapport had such a Innovative creative
Dynamic style that it would allow for
the game to be very interesting very
chaotic as you guys were able to see and
this meant that it would give him some
chances to get a win and then carry that
momentum towards um a better tournament
so very good uh comeback from Magnus
let's go into to the next game which was
him with the black pieces against uh St
Louis favorite Fabiano caruana so the
game started with E4 D5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 Bishop B5 A6 it's a
Spanish probably you know the most
played um opening in the history it has
a very long running uh theoretical
history lots of players um have played
it from the 1500s to the 21st century
and it doesn't seem like it's stopping
anytime soon Bishop to A4 Knight to F6
Castle Bishop to E7 Rook to E1 Pawn to
B5 B3 castles everything normal so far
A4 trying to open up the um the a
file and putting some pressures onto
this B5 Pawn it's a very common idea
especially if you as white pieces want
to want to drop the pawn structure from
the
opponent Pawn to B4 was played A5 D6 C3
Rook B8 if uh White decides to take then
the B file is open and there can be a
lot of pressure The Rook is on the
perefect spot so H3 was played Pawn to
H6 Pawn to D4 going for the center and
after B takes C3 B takes C3 e takes D4
Knight takes D4 Bishop to D7 now in this
position uh which has been reached
before the
main uh the most
noticeable aspect is the pawn structure
from White right the pawn on e4 C3 and
A5 in general uh you don't want to have
that many Pawn Islands you want to have
as little Pawn Islands as possible that
way all the pawns are connected and they
support each other um however white is
trying to get uh some compensation in
the form of initiative for this bone
structure and after Bishop to F4 Knight
to
E5 Knight to A3 Knight to A3 it might
look a little bit strange because it's
not it's going to the rim of the board
but there's a big problem with Knight to
D2 which is Knight to
D3 and the whole point is that this
Knight is going to eventually go to C4
hopefully trade off for this centered
Knight here on E5 and uh just improve
the pieces finishing of the
development Rook 28 was played Bishop to
G3 Bishop to f8 and pawn to F4 um
whenever I see the move Pawn to F4 I get
very excited it's one of my favorite
moves to make and obviously white is
gaining a lot of uh Center control after
this move as well as a Tempo on the
Knight on E5 however we have to always
take into account the possible risks
that come from a pawn move especially
moving the F Pawn right which mean this
diagonal right
here uh for the moment that diagonal is
very difficult to access as the bishop
on f8 doesn't have a clear route to it
and and at the same time this bishop on
G3 still does a very good job of
covering all the necessari squares but
we'll see if this move is successful or
not Knight to F6 uh makes sense to go
for an exchange of pieces after the
opponent has weakened their Pawn
structure and pawn to E5 was played now
obviously as we can see white is going
uh for the attack in the center with the
with the pawns the question is does this
work or does it not so far black hasn't
done any major blunder or any major
mistake they have uh followed the chess
principles and the position has looked
completely fine up until now so it would
be very rare if uh there's some sort of
winning initiative here for white that
just um ends the game with the pawns
pushing
forward however uh this Pawn to E5 also
has the possibility of opening up the
diagonal for this uh dark Square Bishop
so we'll be able to see how the Bishops
play a big role into this position and
after d takes E5 F takes
E5 uh even though the Knight is hanging
right here on F6 black is going to have
enough tactical play to compensate and
lead the position towards a
favorable
continuation with should definitely take
into account the fact that a lot of the
white pieces seem slightly uncoordinated
like don't get me wrong this bishop on
B3 definitely puts pressure on F7 and
the Knight is centralized here on D4 but
at the same time the bishop is kind of
looking at
A3 and it almost feels like there are
too many things um hanging by a thread
Knight takes D4 C takes D4 and now a
really beautiful move Bishop to C6
Magnus said in his interview that at
first he wasn't so sure about the
evaluation of his position as uh Fabiano
was pushing his pawns forward but once
he realized this move Bishop to C6 he
knew that everything would be fine it is
a very nice move and the whole idea is
that if e takes F6 which you know seems
like a free piece there is actually Rook
takes E8 Rook takes E1 um the most
natural continuation is Bishop takes E1
because of Queen takes E1 there is just
uh Rook takes B3 and the pawn on D4 is
hanging the uh Knight on A3 is hanging
even the bishop on G3 is a little bit um
under pressure so Bishop takes E1 and
here you realize okay the queen is
defending the bishop on B3 as well as
defending the pawn on D4 if my queen
gets on to D4 it's attacking the rook
and the king at the same time so let's
go Rook takes B3 and after Rook takes B3
it's impossible to to hold on to
everything and as as I was mentioning
earlier The Bishop's putting a lot of
pressure uh White pieces kind of hanging
on by a thread and after Queen takes B3
Queen takes D4 King to H1 Queen takes A1
the position would be completely winning
for black not only because of the
material but also because there are just
so many uh loose pieces and in general
the bishop pair is incredibly strong
so Fabiano did not take on
F6 but instead he played this move
Bishop to C2 and you know at First
bishop to C2 looks like a normal move
perhaps uh it's preparing Queen to D3
the threat of e takes F6 is still alive
so black needs to do something about it
but the fact that the bishop went away
from such a crucial diagonal means that
Magnus has a move now that is completely
winning and you don't often see in the
lead games a position where one of the
sides is uh winning on move 22 but after
Queen to
D5 what does white do right because the
bishop and the queen they have a very
clear threat which is this Pawn on G2
and it is very easy to attack because
the white pawns have been pushed so
forward so Rook to E2 was played in the
game Queen 2 E2 uh would have also
defended the pawn but this Pawn on D4
would be hanging then and if Queen to D2
trying to defend that pawn uh there is a
really beautiful idea that kind of
coincides with how the game went so I
don't want to show it right now I want
to give you a time to think but after
Rook to E2 feel free to try and guess
the best move here for black if you want
to pause the video you can do that
but the continuation would be Rook to
B4 and this is a very strong move
because how do you defend the pawn on D4
right Bishop to F2 is impossible because
it would block the rook and the
Checkmate threat on G2 uh would come to
life and of course if uh e takes of six
trying to get some material there is
still Rook takes E2 Queen takes
E2 and queen takes D4 with a double
threat
so after Rook to B4 it is almost
impossible for black to from white to
defend actually it is impossible for
white to defend um there is just no way
to keep everything under control and the
lack of
coordination really makes it difficult
to come up with a cohesive plan King to
H2 Rook takes D4 and not too long after
uh m know ended up winning the game
let's just see the final moves Bishop
takes E4 Rook takes E4 Queen takes
Stakes any end game that you can get
where you have a pair of Bishops and
your opponent has bishop and knight uh
you have a slight Edge because your
pieces coordinate better together um and
in this case the two Bishops are just
going to completely dominate the board
Knight to
C4 Rook to B8 Rook to C1 Rook B5 going
after the weaknesses that the pawn lives
Left Behind which uh we mentioned would
be very uh catastrophic once we got to
the end game Pawn to E6 F takes C6
Bishop takes C7 Rook to C5 and there's
no way to keep everything under control
after Bishop to D5 Fabiano decided to
resign and this was the second wing for
Magnus after his two previous losses and
he's making his way back into the into
the leaders board
and actually that's not the end of the
story so let's go over the next
game where uh Magnus Carlson is playing
uh with the black pieces against uh
param maulu and this is after a draw in
between so Magnus played his game
against Fabiano then had a draw then is
now playing this game and something that
I find very fascinating is that it
almost feels like there is no no rush
often times when us peasants um have a
bad streak at a
tournament uh we want to go into our
next game and go for a win throw all of
our pieces into the opponent's face try
to find some sort of Checkmate and try
to destroy them in the most embarrassing
way possible for them but no there's
some maturity that comes with playing
chess over the years and you need to
understand yourself and you need to
understand your tournament situation
something very admirable I think for
from Magnus is the fact that yes he did
have a strategy against
Rapport uh he took some time to to cool
off during the rest days he prepared for
his game report it went his way and then
for his game against Fabiano actually in
his interview he mentioned that he was
just planning to play a solid game to be
fair he's playing with the black pieces
is one of the uh most consistent top
players in the in the
world and luckily enough things just
went his way now Magnus is going to keep
that streak and let's see how the last
game of the tournament up up until now
uh went his way so let's see house this
game against param went it started off
with D4 D5 once again Magnus is with the
black pieces Pawn to E6 Knight to C3
Knight to F6 C takes D5 e takes D5
Bishop to G5 Bishop B7 E3 and H6 for a
long time it it was thought that this uh
Quin scambi decline Orthodox variations
were not uh good enough for black to
equalize but it seems like they have
been um coming back to life in the past
couple of years even lines with uh de
Janowski variation with Pawn to A6 in
the third move and clearly here we can
see that if you know even the world
champions are playing it it means that
there is some some life and fire to it
pawn to H6 Bishop to H4 Bishop to G4 and
here peram went for the very interesting
Queen to
A4 um in general F3 kind of fits with
the idea because after B Bishop to E6
often times you see uh Bishop to D3
Knight to E2 and white is playing to
keep pushing in the center with Pawn to
E4 but instead Queen to A4 was played
Pawn to C6 and Bishop to
D3 CLE Pawn to H3 Bishop to H5 and
Magnus is essentially saying okay I have
no fear you can go G4 if you want to
which to be fair kind of looks like an
attractive move but after Bishop to G6
uh this bishop is under attack so
something needs to be done about it and
if Bishop takes G6 F takes G6 the f file
is open and it's open in favor of black
because they already have a rook placed
there uh
this this diagonal is going to cause a
lot of pressure for white as well and
with ideas of the Knight jumping over to
E4 and some possible exchange the pawn
on F2 being a little bit loose and white
not finish with development and safety
of the king only means that whatever
attack they're planning to do is just
simply not going to work especially in
general terms uh when the queen is on
the complete opposite side of the
opponent's king you would rather bring
it back before you start the attack
because from here there's no way that it
can get anywhere close to black king so
uh now that we agree that white needs to
take it a little bit slow and they can't
just go throwing pawns Queen to C2 was
played Pawn to C5 and the idea is very
clear okay uh we can create a pair of
fixed pawns here in the center but most
importantly where does this King go it
needs to go somewhere soon uh the bishop
prevents it from castling long and if
the E file opens up it's going to be a
terrible situation for the king so Pawn
to G4 finally played C takes D4 e takes
D4 Bishop to G6 there is no fear Bishop
takes Pawn takes Queen takes G6 and you
might be thinking okay Magnus just gave
up a pawn what is this doesn't really
make any sense but uh now is when the
fireworks begin to happen if you want
you can once again take a moment to try
and guess what was the next move that
Magnus played in this position but uh
I'm going to go ahead and show it and it
was Knight takes G4 isn't this just such
a such a beautiful move Knight takes G4
and the idea is that if Bishop takes E7
Queen takes E7 comes with check so
there's no time to take back the Knight
here on G4 the pawn on F2 is still
hanging and uh White has found himself
in a lost
position so uh if Pawn takes a SW Bishop
takes H4 and there's no way to keep
everything under control this Pawn on F2
it's going to be a problem uh Forever
This Pawn on D4 is very weak as well
white uh is going to struggle defending
everything at the same time with the
lack of development that they have and
the king is still in the
center so Queen to E6 was played instead
Rook to F7 uh protecting from the check
and at the same time defending the
bishop on E on E7 h takes G4 Bishop
takes H4 Knight to F3 and queen to
F6 now Magnus is offering a queen trade
uh for the playing U offering a queen
trade in a way that he can then play for
the pawn structure that white has and
continue with the problems in
development that they cannot yet solved
so Queen takes of six Bishop takes F6
Knight takes D5 makes a lot of sense and
there's actually Knight to F6 it's just
essentially saying okay you just won the
pawn on D5 thank you for opening up the
D file now I'm going to use it to put
pressure onto this Pawn on D4 and I'm
going to eventually win
it Rook to D1 was played Rook to E8
Knight to E3 Rook to
E4 Rook to E4 putting pressure onto both
pawns and it's going to be impossible to
defend uh Pawn to D5 was played trying
to get out of the out of the threats and
Knight to
B4 Pawn to D6 Knight to C2 King to E7
takes takes Rook takes
G4 and this hand game is equal but at
the same time it is very double-edged as
you can see the Knight right now has a
hard time jumping forward because the
bishop has such a great control of all
of the squares it works in Long Range as
well so the pawn on B2 is under a lot of
pressure as well as some Rook G2 ideas
the fact that there is Aon on D6 can
work for white but it can also work for
black why because it is very close to
the black territory and at any point
they can try and go after it and it
would be difficult for the white pieces
to to protect
it so
uh practically I think that it's a lot
easier to play as black and my point is
kind of proven by how the game continued
Rook to D5 Rook to D7 always make sure
to block pass pawns otherwise they're
just going to keep going forever until
they promote into a queen Rook to F1
Bishop takes B2 Rook to D3 Bishop to F6
back everything safe and secure Rook to
D5 Rook to B4 with some threats of Rook
B2 as well as Rook B6 Rook D1 King to F7
finally bringing the king over to the
center there's no rush to push any of
the kingside pawns uh that can come
after uh right now the main point is to
try and get rid of the biggest threat
that white could have which is the Pawn
on
D6 Rook to D3 King to E6 Knight to D2 uh
Rook to A4 and all of a sudden you find
that it's quite difficult to keep
everything under control we have a
similar situation now as a previous game
with the queen on D1 this Rook on D3
protects too many things at the same
time so Rook takes A3 and the whole
point is that if the Rook takes King
takes on D5 getting back the rook and
the pawn on D6 still hanging and O
overall Bishop versus knight tends to be
very comfortable for the side that has
the bishop uh plus you know in this
position black is going to be two pawns
up
Rook takes A7 King takes
D6 and after now it's just a matter of
technique but as we know Magnus rarely
ever makes any mistakes uh in ter in
terms of uh endgame technique and he was
able to win the game fairly smoothly
after Knight to E4 King to D5 Knight
takes F6 Pawn takes F6 Rook to A5 King
to C4 and after maneuvering around a
little bit with where the King goes and
where the pawns and Rook go um Magnus
was disabled to push the B Pawn forever
they say that all Rook end games are a
draw but sometimes you know the Fate is
already decided King to B3 Rook to F5
preventing the pawn from going forward
but simply King to A4 and then the pawn
keeps on going the white king is blocked
from getting closer to to the pass pawn
and the there is just no way that
they're going to be able to get there in
time Rook to E6 Rook takes F6 Rook takes
uh
E5 King to D1 and now this is a very
good moment
to uh remember the rules of Rook end
games and um there are more than one
there's more than one way to win there's
King to A3 as well but the cleanest one
is Rook to C5 simply pre preventing The
Rook
um simply preventing the simply
preventing the king from getting closer
and with the
pawn uh the end game is completely won
so Rook to A6 King to B3 Rook to D6 and
after King to B2 the pawn keeps on
marching and at the end of the day it's
just going to
be a very simple one so those are uh
three amazing wins from Magnus Carlson
after having lost two games in the
tournament um this type of comeback is
not very common you don't often see uh
such a Revival of a chess player at a
tournament after suffering from very bad
scores but this is Manos scarton he's
the world champion for a reason he has a
ton of experience he understands himself
he has confidence in himself so once
again for the players that are at home
and and often times play tournaments and
don't know how to come back from A Loss
remember that there's just so much more
to come after there is going to be a
calm after the storm understand yourself
trust in your abilities trust that this
is just a rough patch and plan a
strategy for your comeback the more you
play the more experience you get I hope
this games gave you some inspiration for
your future tournaments uh it was a
great time commentating on this games
once again my name is ala cantes and see
you next time bye-bye